what you've seen right now is a calm
submissive pit so he's in a follower
state he's just curious Cesar prepares
to pick up gizmo in front of Julie and
Mark unsure I'm not ready yet
this is shutting down what I'm what I'm
asking right now is to follow the leash
so if the leash moved this way you
follow that's all I'm asking this is
much better state better than the one
you saw seconds ago and that is it it
seems very alert like Keith he's a
little quiet which the quietness is what
can lead him into aggression you can
predict what could happen or you can
create what you want so what I want is
to grab him and put it in my arms so
here grab right here to block the neck
derry-o right quietness you don't put it
down yet you wait until he relaxes
excellent still quiet right
gizmo he has learned to control people
with aggression
whatever happened right now you can't
really keep it in mind because that will
block you from what you really want
let's go back to where he did really
good so we don't make a bad experience
out of that when you have an aggressive
dog the best thing you have to go after
it's respect because it will hurt you
so this is a case where if you remove
owners you will see a totally different
state of mind the next step is to put
the honor to the test now it's time to
up the ante for gizmo and Julie Cesar
brings them both outside for a walk with
other dogs and their handlers definitely
the weakest link is Julie so we need to
make sure we empower Julie go nice relax
the arm there we go much better yeah
that's a good one
don't let him focus on anything else
except you and what you're thinking
correction to the side very nice
that's good I always believe that people
have this assertive side of them and
that's my goal to help you to bring it
out what's the difference between the
way you normally do it and the way
you're doing it now
more calm and assertive I was good I was
good
I just wanted to get one light bulb
because I did many exercise don't forget
to clean this space very good it was an
opportunity for me to show okay this is
what I would do in this situation there
we go relax the tension there you go
even his demeanor changes by being in a
pack he's just being a beagle right now
that's her new job dog walker now that
julie has had a taste of success walking
with gizmo Cesar moves them inside to
tackle the aggression issue that sent
mark to the hospital gizmos
possessiveness over his food this is
good this is alert attentive okay so if
I were to reach down right now I get
bitten
hey go shake
do you so how I confront him I didn't
move when he was fighting I waited for
him to let go then I make a forward move
cuz everytime he let go and show
weakness that second I took over liking
you the same thing the same thing that's
when I felt like ah just stay there stay
in the ground we went from this passive
human touch
hey make sense that's what I want I want
to bring more this up energy that allows
you to see what you need to do once you
know what you need to do the only thing
you need to do is do it that's a big
milestone to me
this is just the beginning and I
definitely can see that there's a light
at the end of the tunnel